the underlying goal is to catalyze the
emergence of beneficial general
intelligence and I mean this just has a
bunch of different aspects making a
decentralized AI platform that's owned
by everyone and no one and can't be
controlled by the power elite is one
aspect yes
making compassionate loving robots that
can be meditation assistants no elder
care workers teachers and carry out
other good works in the world that this
this is another piece of it
the use of our AI technology to try to
cure aging and disease by analyzing
genomic and medical data it's a lot of
different projects but actually they're
all connected together in a common core
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki on we
are at the transformative technology
conference it is fantastic here there's
so many diverse brilliant minds we are
now sitting down with dr. Ben Kurtz oh
hello Hey it's pleasure to be here thank
you for coming on to the show really
appreciate it and Ben is known as one of
the world's leading AI scientists
singularity net Hanson robotics
decentralized AI foundation now Alliance
there's um you're working on so many
other projects so and and he asked for
kids which is nuts
however he ends up doing this is crazy
to me I don't know yet we'll have to
figure it out before we get to all the
epicness of the projects that you're
working on how did you become who you
are where were you born how did you pick
up your interests tell us about that
well I was born in Rio de Janeiro Brazil
to American parents my dad was there
doing his sociology page new work on
Brazilian student politics and when I
was pretty young we moved back to the
u.s. to Eugene Oregon so I sort of grew
up
the crazy hippies of Eugene in the late
60s and early 70s which probably
probably left a mark on me right MA
my dad was a like Marxist sociologist at
that point my my mom was very involved
in you know anti-war protest movement
and then the women's rights movement
civil rights movement all these things
so I sort of grew up in this social
change have a bomb beyond so my my
grandfather my mother's father was a
physical chemist so he taught me a lot
about science and sort of sparked that
interest in me his sister was a
physicist also and so I yeah from an
early age I had an interest both in
invents science and then you know
changing the world for the better and I
got interested in science fiction very
young from watching the original Star
Trek with my dad and that's where I
first got the idea of AI there was a
little robot in the original Star Trek
which was like zooming through the
through the galaxies and then you know
Kirk and Spock had to deactivate it by
presenting it with logical paradoxes and
I thought that made no sense it was like
three or four years old I'm like if this
AI is so smart like how can it be full
but these childish paradoxes with it but
it piqued my interest I started reading
science fiction and sometime around 73
or so I counted a book by Gerald
Feinberg a physicist called the
Prometheus project and he said within a
few decades humanity is going to create
superhuman AI molecular nanotechnology
and human immortality and then the
choice will be whether we develop this
new apparently firm materialistic
purposes or for spiritual advancement
and yes I was maybe seven eight years
old read this book in the local library
I'm like well that's interesting why
isn't anyone talking about this right
and so then I you know I became more
interested in AI in psychology and
and time-travel life-extension biology
physics all sorts of things and
eventually in my late 20s I got a math
page I graduated college when I was 18
at a math PhD at 22 and shortly after
that started working on AI and quickly
realized that you know it was a big job
to build the general intelligence but
seemed like a feasible and possible
thing to do and started pushing on that
start trying to build AI systems with
potential for general intelligence in
the mid 90s and AI start up in New York
in the late 90s which sort of rose and
fell with the dot-com bubble was in DC
doing AI consulting for companies and
government agencies from its 2002
through 2011 and all the while sort of
developing my ideas on how to build
general intelligence further and further
as well as doing research in a whole
bunch of different areas that we
probably won't talk about today like
life extension biology and the science
of the paranormal and lots of weird
stuff and is that what OpenCog OpenCog
has been a project since 2008 so there's
been a series of AI systems I've worked
on which had sort of common principles
but each one advanced further and
further so between 97 and 2001 we had an
AI system called web mind and then from
2000 and 2001 we started a company
called Nova monta which is an AR
consulting company and we built a system
called Nova meant a cognition engine in
2008 we open-source pieces of that to
form OpenCog so OpenCog formally started
2008 that it was built on some software
and ideas have been developed a long
time before that so we've been trying to
gradually work toward artificial general
intelligence for for quite some time and
then of course I moved to Hong Kong in
2011 and why did you make that
I fell in love with the Chinese woman
basically yes that's the real crux of it
but a lot of other things fell into
place also yeah I mean I got around the
reason I start going to Asia is in 2007
you know my friend curzio Vasa poyo do
me an economic chart proving to me that
the u.s. is going to go bankrupt on
September 25th 2008 which was right
around the time Lehman Brothers went
broke right so we sort of had the idea
that there was gonna be a financial
crisis so I started getting some
contracts to do AI for companies in
Japan we're talking to a Korean
University friend of mine hello remember
working your antifragility in advance
yeah yeah that's so cool start looking
at some Chinese universities now on this
tour around China two things happen I
met writing who's not my wife in Xiamen
China where she was doing her PhD and
that met a guy named Gino you in Hong
Kong and we we applied for a research
grant together and got a research grant
in Hong Kong Pali you for some OpenCog
research aimed at video game characters
and robots so there's a woman and then
there's a research grant
yeah and on the other hand my my kids
who and I've been I've been raising in
Washington DC we're growing up and going
away to college so it was sort of a time
when that was it was it was convenient
to make a move and I was also getting a
bit worn out on the US military
intelligence industry which I mean yeah
at that time was sort of the the best
and almost the only way to get paid as
an independent AI researcher and I mean
I'm grateful for you know having had
work to do for Northrop Grumman SAIC and
and so forth ultimately for government
clients I mean it paid my bills and let
me support an AI team in Brazil while
doing some a gir D but around that same
time you know the AI ecosystem was
developing further it was becoming
possible to make a living doing AI for
things other than military and
audience and so I moved to Hong Kong
which your parents would be like yeah
that's getaway no I mean you know it was
mostly good hearted well-meaning people
and in DC that I work with who really
felt like they're protecting the world
from bad things and they and you know
they are protecting the world from a lot
of badness so there's a amazing number
of nasty things that almost happened and
they're averted by the by intelligence
agencies this is when people say oh yeah
yeah it's so big and I'm like but
there's a lot of things that were saying
here because of there's a lot of things
I didn't agree with they're told it but
there's also a lot of a lot also a lot
of good that was done and I'm in the
world is complicated place but on the
whole I'm happier now not not working on
that right and so in Hong Kong I did a
bunch of things i did a machine learning
based hedge fund I did this research
with a genome and then I had a good
friend named David Hanson who was in
Texas doing humanoid robotics I
introduced it to some people in Hong
Kong who ultimately got him funding for
his company he moved to Hong Kong
Abrahamson about songkong which is a
beautiful place to do robotics because
across the border in shenzhen you have
the world's hotbed of of consumer
electronics manufacturing hardware
generally yes so I became chief
scientist of Henson robotics and you
know at that time David was creating the
original Sophia robot he had a bunch of
other cool robots thank you Miss deploy
the stamp is 20 Sofia was launched in
2015 I think the original sculpture
rather in 2014 okay at that time he had
some other robots we were experimenting
with first robot on stein and philip k
dick and being a 48 and so forth so then
we decided it would be interesting to
use the OpenCog engine as sort of a
beefed up control system for the henson
robots
yeah and that we started working on that
in 2014 and now like as of the last
month we're starting to really use
OpenCog within the henson robots in in
public appearances and so forth it was a
was a bit of a journey to get there just
because we'd never used OpenCog for a
real-time control
before we'd used it analyzed genetics
data or to analyze stock market in for
the stock market and when used it for no
research advanced machine reasoning
controlling the robots was the first
time we'd used the OpenCog AI system to
to control the real-time system which
required a lot of changes and David and
I had a lot of common interests and we
common interest in the benevolent
singularity and philip k dick we also
had a common interest in making a robot
mind cloud like a cloud a cloud based
framework for storing the knowledge of
many many different areas and robots
they'll share information which became
singularity and yeah yeah and that grew
into singular you know I mean we could
see that you know etherion based smart
contracts and the blockchain and quantum
computing should all should all feed
into this and then I met Simone a Jochum
le a young blockchain guru from from
Italy due to David Hansen basically
introduced me to a friend of Simone ace
and then brought Simone a to Hong Kong
and when Simone a-and I met we
immediately saw how to create the
singularity in that that was May 2017
then we raised some seed funding for
that in July 2017 and then did a whole
bunch of publicity and software
development and concept refinement did a
token generation event
token sale in December 2017 and now
basically that's been going full speed
ahead we're launching the beta of the
singular unit you know blockchain base
decentralized a imine cloud project in
february of next year and we're now
we're doing a spin-off of singular unit
called singular estudio aimed at aimed
at basically building enterprise
software applications for pharma FinTech
iot and so on leveraging the singularity
net platform so this is now yeah
exploding in all different directions I
mean the underlying goal is to catalyze
the emergence of beneficial general
intelligence and I mean this just has a
bunch of different aspects making a
decentralized AI platform that's owned
by everyone and no one and can't be
controlled by the power elite
one aspect yes making compassionate
loving robots that can be meditation
assistance you know elder care workers
teachers and carry out other good works
in the world that this this is another
piece of it the use of our our
technology to try to cure aging in
disease by analyzing genomic and medical
data that's another aspect of it I mean
I started doing cloud based machine
learning for longevity genomics in 2002
three before it was possible before it
was popular rather and you know now
we're progressing much further with that
so it's a lot of different projects but
actually they're all connected together
in a common core totally ok so I love it
because this is what I care about so
much and what a lot of people really
care about in the field of being being
really proper adequate loving caring
stewards for Earth so we have a general
intelligence benevolent one that nobody
owns but people are able to access and
contribute to and then we have a
benevolent robotics loving caring robots
that can help Society them forward and
then also the just understanding all of
this beautiful data within our bodies
and then and then increasing our our our
longevity being really key staying
healthy longer
so so these things are just I love it I
love it I'm so happy you're doing it I
can't believe you're able to balance all
of this stuff
so now let's and also when you first
started talking about you being a kid I
was I was you know no no I don't really
know that many people when they're like
you know there are three and seven when
they're starting to really unpack these
really into these really interesting I
guess ways of seeing the future that
excite them at that young of an age so I
would also really like to see more young
kids have the sense of youthful
inspiration that you had that catalyzed
you to finish your PhD when you were 22
and start companies and and build the
future so okay let's I guess let's
start by asking you about the
convergence of all of this is
fascinating it's multidisciplinary a lot
of people see it see it that way that
it's sooo nuanced and intricate
multivariate so how do you figure out
where these things overlap and how to
how because you know you know way more
about AI and machine learning then then
of course me and even a lot of people
that even that here even in the field
how do you know where to allocate
resources for like how things overlap
and so you don't have to build it twice
well I think I I tend to have a fairly
abstract point of view on things I mean
my PhD was in math and I always tended
to philosophy of mind in metaphysics and
so forth so I tend to look at the more
abstract patterns binding everything
together and so from from that point of
view these things that appear different
are not that different I mean the AI
system and then the economy in which
single area acts and the human body I
mean these are all complex
self-organizing patterns systems and if
you look at things in this more abstract
sort of pattern dynamics point of view
then the commonality is even more
apparent than the differences and of
course computer science supports that it
can be the same data structures and
algorithms dealing dealing with all
these all these things I mean of course
to do real things in the real world
there's endless amounts of nitty-gritty
issues and compromises that need to be
made because even though these systems
are in some sense of common organizing
principles and dynamics I mean if you're
doing bioinformatics you need to hire
people who know the nitty-gritty of
molecular biology if you're doing
robotics I mean you need people who are
good at connecting the anchor from the
motor to the inside inside of the
robot's face so the
the biggest sort of leap I made in my
life probably was from being a theorist
trying to understand everything to
trying to build stuff and do stuff which
rapidly verged into leading teams
building stuff and then doing stuff
because theory you can do as one guy
just sitting there thinking and coming
up with one idea after another but at
the level of complexity of modern
technology there's only so far one guy
can go in programming a complex system
or building a piece of hardware or
analyzing a biology system so - that was
a burner ship that was a big leap from
theory into entrepreneurship and sort of
technology leadership and that probably
has not increased my overall happiness
level I would I would say you wanna
interesting and but but that has been
exciting you know yeah and it's very
interesting you you're making real stuff
and of course there's a level of
understanding you only get by engaging
in making real stuff that you'll just
never get but by sitting and theorizing
I mean not to minimize the value of what
you get by sitting and theorize and they
were like I mean I love I love the
philosophy of continets you and all
these guys who sat and thought and went
down a certain intellectual rabbit hole
as far as it can possibly go right
that's really cool yeah on the other
hand by engaging in groups of people and
by engaging in the physical world with
complex technologies I mean you
certainly gain the different different
sort of understanding of things so it's
been it's been super interesting but I
would say I keep saying after another
one or two more years of this I'm gonna
take a step back and focus on theory of
real research again yes but it it keeps
not happening because there's more and
more interesting and amazing stuff to
build right yeah it's cool how you go
through heavy theory heavy
entrepreneurship back to heavy fear
looking
to do heavy I'm still doing both but I
do look I do theory in odd moments here
and there and I know there's a
limitation because too sometimes you
just need to spend like a few months
like 15 hours a day bearing down on some
on some conceptual thing and I don't
have time for that right now while
running these different projects but
that's I mean I can't complain because
these are all really really amazing
things so I mean it may be within a
couple years there's enough stable
management in place for the various
projects I'm doing that I can step back
and spend like two-thirds of my time on
theory again there's something and you
do one of the biggest keys for you then
is to find people that can do the work
as well as you can or as close to as
well a lot of people who are much better
than me a lot of people I mean there's
we have loads of amazing software
engineers and my programming skill has
degenerated since I've been doing other
things for so long and of course in in
biology we have people who have this
comprehensive knowledge of the human
body at all different levels worse I
know a decent amount of biology but I'm
not at that level and of course David
Hanson and his team not only have more
technical knowledge of robotics David as
this amazing artistic flair for creating
systems that can connect to people right
and that's that's been a really
interesting thing so I I saw how some
people were just connecting to this
Sofia robot on the intuitive almost
animal level and I mean that's where I
thought well let's try having her be a
meditation guide or something because it
seems like can we leverage this spooky
connection that some people feel to the
robot to cut grab people and then push
them in the direction of positive growth
and consciousness expansion right but I
would never have thought of that if not
for you know engaging with David Hanson
and his technology which is based on his
background then you know film and arts
and narrative and a whole different part
of the universe and then the things that
I was used to now how does one you're
talking about this abstract thinking
that I love so much - its
multidisciplinary it's it's it's kids
it's calculating a lot it's synthesizing
calculating analyzing synthesizing
information I love that style of
thinking then to take that and then go
and build something practical into the
world that there's there are a lot of
intervening steps actually yeah tell us
about the that's a challenge I mean I
think the approach we took with OpenCog
was sort of like having a high-level
theory of how a mind should work to have
human-like intelligence within
restricted computational resources and
then sort of going bottom-up saying what
could I build using available data
structures and algorithms that would
then satisfy the constraints of this
high-level theory so it wasn't so much
that we started from the high-level
theory and built down which I tried but
didn't get anywhere it didn't get far
enough but you start with a high level
theory then you try to design up but
you're constrained by matching with a
high level of theory so you're sort of
going in a way bottom-up and top-down at
the same time in a meeting and I think
in biology it's in biology it's sort of
the same way like you to combat aging
you need a systems understanding of
aging and now things are going wrong in
different parts of the body different
levels of the body how the different
systems are interacting but then if
you're designing a therapy you're
probably still poking like a small
number of genes or molecules but you
want to poke that small number of genes
or molecules and in a way that fits in
with the higher-level understanding that
you have and if you don't do that you're
just going to make a localized
remedy rather than
really them really help so for example
you can look in aging it like the
extracellular matrix the the molecules
in between the cells and the body in
between the organs this gets stiffer as
you get older and older and from a
systems you can see this is very
important because this is this is where
signaling happens in different parts of
the body the contours are the
extracellular matrix correlate with
acupuncture pathways so there's there's
a lot of systems understanding that
tells you why the ECM is important but
then if you want to fix that then
whether you do well okay why is it get
stiff there's these cross-linked
proteins for example there's glucose
apeun molecules so we're working with
Christian chef master at Temple
University to design like another
technology based molecular scissors of
Spira ligament molecules to cut the
cross linked glucose apeun molecules
right so they're they're you starting
with Christians nanotech technology and
like what can you do with it which will
be valuable in the context of this this
systems model of aging so you you got to
start with the whole system and start
with what your particular tools can do
and find the middle ground with a where
that were they meet yeah that that's
thought process is actually extremely
important a lot of people come in with a
vision for how they want to change the
world and then I'm always like amazing
vision like what are the short-term
steps to get there and then it's also
important to see how does the vision
meet the short-term steps yeah I'm in
the middle that's really cool Ben I like
that a lot run us run us through right
now there seems to be a lot of
artificial intelligence that is coming
into the world and how does one
accumulate that into the general
intelligence singularity net and then
how do how do people access there's the
general intelligence how do they apply
it to their practices yeah this is a
complex story unsurprisingly so I mean
we can really look at what we're making
is a I guess a network of networks of
networks you know and
way and of but of course human life is
that the brain is a network embedded in
the larger network of the body embedded
in the larger network of society embed
in the larger network of the ecosystem
right so AI has multiple levels like
that also so I have the OpenCog system
whose knowledge representation is a
network a weighted labeled hyper graph
and there's multiple AI algorithms
acting on this common knowledge graph
such as some neural nets for pattern
recognition a logic engine to deal with
abstract knowledge and reasoning
evolutionary learning which evolves and
creates new things and these all work
together on this common knowledge graph
which then has a goal system associated
with it
and you can try to choose actions that
it thinks will help achieve its goals
given the current context for the
understanding of the context and the
actions is given by all the knowledge in
this graph right so that's OpenCog which
in itself is very complicated and we
worked on for a long time in sum which i
think is quite good at generalization
and abstraction we're still working on
optimizing it but I think the core is
there the singularity net is a platform
in which multiple ai's may be based on
quote different principles can be
networked together so they can all talk
to each other they can all communicate
share data with each other outsource
processing to each other so these AIS
can provide services to outside users
that can be used in the backend various
software products and websites but the
eyes can also outsource services to each
other in complex patterns and so that's
it's another level of network right so I
think you need some a eyes in there that
have a fundamental power of
generalization and abstraction like
OpenCog does but this can then work
together with simpler types of AI and
they can coordinate together into a
network whose intelligence in a way is
greater than the sum of the parts I mean
so you can look at that sort of like how
you know different organs in the body or
network together I mean and they each
have their own intelligence but the
whole obviously is more coordinated
behavior than the sum of the parts and
then in different cities yeah as well
then we're also working on something
called the Daiya the decentralized AI
alliance and that's an alliance of
different decentralized AR projects so
singularity that is ours which networks
together OpenCog with a bunch of other
guys but then there are other projects
like ocean protocol which is a
blockchain based decentralized data
network there's sebum which is a
decentralized network for genomics based
AI those deep-brain chain which uses
blockchain for fast training of deep
neural networks cost many machines so we
want to network together these different
decentralized AI networks into a sort of
network of network so that's why we have
network of networks of networks and all
these levels it's complicated but that's
what we see in nature yeah and I think I
think in different ways that's what we
see on the internet already so I think
that's the right way to think about that
doesn't mean you don't need core
generalization and abstract reasoning
algorithms in there it's just that these
and in some ways you could say these are
the crux of it for AGI but all the other
parts are important too I mean just as
in your cortex there's certain micro
circuits that are really good at
abstract learning and reasoning but if
you just put these micro circuits in a
vat yeah they're just gonna abstractly
reason about their own abstract
reasoning in sort of the vacuous loops
right it's by putting them in the
network of the brain which is the
network of the body of the society of
the ecosystem that you're getting you're
really giving these abstract learning
circuits the ability to prove their
worth yes yes okay I liked how you were
describing it it finally started coming
together more more for me and I and I
and I like that and hopefully for others
as well okay now is when when you feed a
when you're feeding OpenCog which has
the ability to abstract the reason when
you're feeding it and to do of some sort
how does it parse that and make sense of
what it needs to do within its
within its framework to bring about the
result the OpenCog can ingest a lot of
different types of knowledge so I mean
there's a language parser where it
parses out English language now into
nodes and links to try to represent the
semantics of that English language it
doesn't always work but sometimes
sometimes it does and you can also take
computer programs like little Lisp
programs or something and import those
and then they turn into nodes and links
and it's not in its knowledge base we
also have like specialized data
importers four types of biology
knowledge for example or accounting
knowledge and so forth and these when
you import the data it it goes into the
whole and it's organized into a bucket
of buckets know it's areas not buckets
it's organized into nodes and links to
each other it's or not never the buckets
no it's not partition you exactly Sam
but then there's the reasoning engine
looks at the nodes and links that came
from data including vision and hearing
as well as databases and language and
the reasoning engine takes those nodes
and links that came from the outside
world and builds new nodes and links
okay and that's how ok and then that's
how you add to it yeah yeah and then and
then I mean what reasoning does is takes
empirical knowledge and then generates
new knowledge based on the empirical
nodes and then and then what when you're
when you prompt when you're adding the
knowledge and then you're trying to get
what the an answer of sorts from that
how does one how does it compute there
is a tool called the pattern matcher in
OpenCog so if you want to find a
collection of nodes and links matching a
certain pattern you submit a query and
it searches the whole knowledge based
upon things matching that pattern and
then there's the logical backward
chainer which if you give a pattern and
tries to find things that approximately
or probabilistically match that pattern
and so if you're asking a question some
way or another that question is turned
into
a crisp or probabilistic pattern
matching query that goes against the
whole knowledgebase okay and then now oh
yeah we're getting pretty deep in the
weeds those yeah but that's really
important adding the knowledge making
the query and then getting some sort of
results and and this is what I want to
do a little bit as the roots as the deep
roots and then also then I see the
OpenCog with singularity net able to
work with the different AI said yes so I
mean if someone makes a great AI for say
recognizing patterns in in videos or or
say for importing data from accounting
spreadsheets or something you want an
easy way for that to feed knowledge into
an abstraction engine like like OpenCog
grows and so singularity that makes an
easy way for different their eyes
written by all sorts of different people
to connect together and I mean if
someone else makes a different reasoning
engine with different strengths and
weaknesses relative to OpenCog that can
be there in the singular and unit also
then some application you consult two
different reasoning engines and decide
which answer it looks better or one of
the reasoning engines if it gets stuck
halfway through doing reasoning you
could ask a question of a different
reasoning engine that could help it get
unstuck right so there's a lot of
potential to having different AI is able
to compete with and consult each other
within a common Network interesting
compete and consult with each other in
the I networks interesting and then the
and then the decentralized AI Alliance
gets in there as well so this is more
new this is your newest that that's that
that's that's new yeah we announced that
a few months ago but we're still forming
it I mean the idea there so there's a
bunch of projects are using blockchain
related technologies to make
decentralized AI networks that are owned
by the participants and democratically
controlled and they have different
focuses so I mean singular Tina is a
pretty generic framework for
interconnecting AI is now deep brain
change for example is a decentralized
network that
is really fast at training deep neural
nets and Shivam is a decentralized ad
network that specifically gathers
genomic data from people stores it
securely and then does some analytics on
the genomics data right so we don't need
to replicate everything they're doing we
just let an agent a note in the
singularity Network talk directly to a
node in the Shivam network or deep
branch chain so if a singularity that
node needs some neural nets trained
really fast and they outsource that to
deep brain chain if a singularity node
is analyzing genomics data and once more
genomics data it might ask the Shivam
blockchain hey do you have any data
filling these criteria that I could use
and then the AGI token which is within
the singularity net ecosystem can be
automatically converted on the back end
into a chief home token to pay for that
and then of course if you have
reputation than rating like if if one
guy has written a bunch of great AI in
singular you know where he has like a
four point five star rating then if he
starts to do something in Shivam he
should get a high braiding by
propagation from things already nuts so
you can have both sharing of data
sharing of currency and sharing of
reputation and ratings among different
decentralized blockchain based and I
related networks and I think this is how
you can build an alternate AI ecosystem
that can really take on the the tech
giants whoa that last part yeah but
there's a lot to be done yeah and it's
it's not just building the tech it's
coordinating a lot a lot of people with
different philosophies ins in the
sentence oh yeah yeah that's right
I love that sort of cool when a query is
sent in you're not even then limited to
what open Coggins you Ares well that's
right then you can access access a whole
bunch of other networks and that's right
I mean that's how I actually shouldn't
be siloed off it should be open networks
connecting the other open networks and
learning and growing from each other
won't the googles and apples and
of the world Facebook's won't they die
if they if they silo themselves and
centralize themselves remains to be seen
I mean I think it's not important to me
that they die but I think they won't be
the dominant factor
I mean IBM didn't die when mainframes
became less important there's still
business niches for them they saw a lot
of mainframes two banks they do services
for big companies but they're not
dominant any more wine computer died
though so yeah I mean I don't say that
Google Microsoft and Facebook will die
without what I say is they will not own
the majority of it of AI anymore and you
know what niches are best for them to
occupy they were that really remains to
be seen right yeah interesting so then
the Giants could turn into niches
because they're the Giants could also
turn into companies selling AI services
on decentralized networks right I mean
there's a lot there's a lot of
possibilities I mean as Microsoft is
morphing into a cloud company right so I
mean the company that's sufficiently
agile the brand name persists but they
can completely add that Microsoft is
offering Linux on Azure all over the
place now instead of instead of Windows
so I mean that we're not opposed to any
particular companies it's more the
centralized modality of organization
that we're trying to we're trying to get
rid of and yes I mean what history
suggests is some of the leading
companies will find a way to adapt to a
new mode of organization of the industry
and some won't find a way to adapt Amil
and they'll disappear I mean I have my
guesses as to which ones will adapt and
which ones won't but I mean the time
will tell
yeah I would say there's a lot of people
in leadership positions with
in Google who understand the singularity
in advanced technology pretty well they
have a fairly strong ability to adapt
and not every big tech company shows
that same ability to adapt but then the
evolution of businesses isn't incredibly
unpredictable right like no one
predicted IBM would be a services
company but yet they meant they managed
to pivot right so it's quite hard to
tell who will pivot to embrace the
decentralized era lucky I mean you can
see that in publishing industry also
right like some publishing companies are
gonna are gonna flourish and and some of
the some of some will disappear yeah now
how do we put our eggs in your basket
because we are we're relying on your
ethical and moral standards with the
general intelligence that you're
building as with anyone who would be
building what we would be relying on
here yeah you're relying on the
community not just me personally sakurai
mean if in the unlikely event like I
were invaded by Martian mud virus and
went batshit crazy and became malevolent
I mean there's a loads of other
contributors to these projects so it's
about ceding a a community of people who
are are thinking in somewhat of a shared
way and aiming to develop things in a
benevolent manner and what are the
guiding principles of your community
that make it ethically and morally just
grounded and that we can trust that sex
drugs and rough sex drugs are going away
yeah yeah besides those besides that
yeah I think I mean an abstract level
the ethical principles I've written
about are basically joy growth choice
and continuity and I think all of these
have have an important value in the
practical con
I mean we're trying to promote happiness
and and doing good them and we try to
have a work environment and the
community that that's fun to be in I
mean we're trying to grow and expand
rapidly and create new patterns great
new things new new technologies new what
new ways of being choice means you know
we want everyone to have agency and that
that's an important part of the whole
decentralized ethos there shouldn't be a
few elites control everything and
continuity means you want to respect the
patterns of history as well as creating
new patterns and this includes like
persisting human beings into the into
the future instead of replacing them
with super ai's it also includes being
respectful of you know historical
cultures that exist now and then certain
people are are very tied into and of
course values like these are very
nebulous ly defined though and sort of
interpreting what they mean is part of
what it what a community does and then
approaching the end here what can we see
come from the Hanson robotics ecosystem
it's look it's looking like we you're
tall we're talking about assisted
meditation well get it so the first
thing is right now there's just a
handful of human skeletons and robots
but we're working with a factory in
Shenzhen to scale up manufacture so we
should have within the next few years of
massive number of robots coming in out
of the factory and I mean these will be
purchased by customers for a variety of
different purposes but the applications
I'm most interested in are those that
are know explicitly promoting wellness
health and growth among among people so
I mean meditation assistant is
interesting I feel like I didn't give
your last your four points enough lower
moment to go I just want to get that's
all right we're gonna go soon I want to
give them love education is interesting
and you
composing this and for having that as an
ethical and moral standard for for
building the community so I just wanted
to I just wanted to say that we're also
looking at making a like a fully
automated hospital room where you have
sort of a Sofia type robot to provide
emotional support and conversation here
here the patient stories tell them
stories answer their questions then you
I mean you have other robots to do
physical things like up someone that
someone in another bed or change the
bedpan or whatever then you have medical
instruments in the room when all of
these are integrated into a singular
unit powered control system for the
hospital room so what's the what's the
practical one that maybe the consumer
can purchase - well I think that for the
human scale robots they're not going to
be that cheap initially so probably the
initial application of the human scale
robots will be sold to stores hospitals
companies and so forth it's gonna be a
few more years after that before the
price comes down enough but then then
when the price is low enough I mean
you'll have home service robots
everywhere just like in the Jetsons
right I mean but much cuter than Rosie
the robot so we're talking maybe like
$10,000 up costs - for now - companies
and/or me even more I'm I don't want to
set the price point cuz it's still -
it's still to be determined it'll be
only least each year actually probably
interesting probably I mean I can't say
for sure because that's answer about the
business decision but I can I can see a
future for a leasing model because
everything is constantly being upgraded
and improved yeah and the other nice
thing is that devoted well being able to
upgrade and improve it the software can
be done remotely but then you do have to
ship in the heart for hardware upgrades
and whatnot yeah yeah hardware is a pain
but it's it's very useful to have yes
yeah okay and then I'm glad that we got
as much as as much as we did I want to
are you or what are your thoughts about
the multiverse what are your thoughts
about about that it's there yeah you
want to know about it a big place yeah
yeah so time happens all at once from
some perspectives yeah I mean I'm a big
fan of revellers relational
interpretation of quantum mechanics
which says that you don't want to talk
about a phenomenon in isolation you talk
about a phenomenon in the context of a
specific observer so an observer come
observe Paris so I mean from our point
of view situated as humans time is
flowing in a certain direction right
from a different point of view which is
a more abstract view of a different sort
of mind than we are then time happens
all along so not only that there's not
just one time axis there's a lot of
different a lot of different time axes
which are sort of floating out there in
the space of patterns right I mean my my
general philosophy view of this is
there's a much wider universe than yeah
then this one that I've used the word
URI Kazem to refer to that like wider
cosmos right so yeah there's a wider
cosmos our physical universe is viewed
as like one conglomeration of patterns
in that wider cosmos and if you want to
look at you know weird poorly understood
phenomena like reincarnation or seances
those suggest that each of our
individual minds has some sort of
existence outside this physical world
and some water because let's lead you to
that quick do you think that does
consciousness is localized in the
central nervous system or that there is
a soul or what do you what are your
thoughts about um the word soul is very
overloaded it would be religious yeah I
mean we don't have a good vocabulary for
these things but but no I
I think consciousness is imminent in
everything in the physical universe and
also goes beyond this physical universe
and that the individual consciousness
associated with each of us can exist at
times in places where our physical body
is not there interesting which suggests
a model in which you know our physical
universe is embedded in some
your space and then maybe the mind
patterns characterizing individual also
have an existence that isn't respected
to this 4d space-time continuum
so that and I've written I've written a
bunch about this if someone Google's the
coinage URI Kazem EU ry Qasim which I
made up and only exists in my writings
on this crazy topic so I mean this is
the sort of stuff I would love to be
thinking about Oh theories on how the
experimentally poke poke at it yeah
because I think you could experiment
okat it by by poking it paranormal
phenomena maybe in animals or something
that said yeah there's a lot of
interesting research directions here and
I sort of look this sort of things
almost where I was when I was a little
kid yeah it's like just gasps it's just
getting started there's limited amount
of understanding no one gives a crap
right so no now I mean I sort of feel
impelled to make a G I really happened
yes on the other hand the part of my
mind was bored with the HEI because I
didn't think I know how to do it and I'm
attracted to think about these other
things that they're large wide open and
I don't I barely know where to begin
which is how I felt when I started with
it right yeah it's so wide open and then
it's so fascinating it's it's it's it's
gonna unlock so much more beauty and
potential it's so cool well an
interesting question is if you have a
superhuman AI will it figure out how to
unlock all these spooky parts of the
universe that we barely understand right
now that would I would imagine so so
yeah I love it well with the with the
general intelligence that that you're
building you'll have a lot to play one
would hope so so anyway we we've reached
the wider multi multi Multi multi
Versalles and cosmos so that that that
may in may indicate the conversation has
a nice wide added to it what what one
time to collapse it down what about the
formation
of the mind of a child that is born into
the world do you have a protocol we do a
pretty good job we have an adequate
amount of you know water and electricity
and food and these basic necessities but
the education of the mind at a young age
and have some basics that that you know
the to expose the children to that you
think would be really helpful moving
forward whoa
I mean I've raised three kids I'm in the
middle of the fourth one but I don't
know that I'm that sister can systematic
about it I
I generally speak to my kids as if they
were adults and just explained the world
of them in a simple but reasonable way
and I tried to teach them all a lot of
math science literature arts history and
so forth and one of them oh the Sun
became a mathematician an AI researcher
the others didn't like math so much but
they each learned a lot and within their
own own direction I mean my my second
son is a Sufi mystic and an amazing
classical pianist so they're yeah I mean
my my daughter did degree in
environmental science and this is
helping with the education in Ethiopia
now so yeah I mean I think kids
intrinsically are curious and
open-minded so if you I mean if you let
them explore different things and expose
them to a lot of different information
they're mostly going to get a grow in a
beneficial way but this is like standard
progressive education doctrine though I
would say I'm working with UNESCO and
with Bethlehem desi who's in our
Ethiopia office on defining and advanced
technology based curriculum which we
want to roll out in schools around the
world K through 12 so I helped define
the I helped define sir that I had a
high level the curriculum and then folks
at UNESCO are working on the details and
we're going to be testing that in
schools in three or four countries over
the next couple years but this is it's
more about like let's get some cool
technologies and let's put them in the
hands of K
yeah just in a way where they can
explore and experiment with them but
let's also get school systems and
various nations to embrace this so that
by doing this kids aren't doing
something off to the side that doesn't
help them pass the university entrance
exam but that what they learned through
this experimentation with the AI
robotics biotech or something ties in
with with how they're assessed let them
let them move forward through the
country's education system yeah so I'm
guessing that experiential agile yeah
you could check the challenges we sort
of know we know how to do that and I
homeschooled all my kids are very sports
to the parts of the childhood I was also
co-founded a charter school in New
Jersey so I mean I see like progressive
education methodologies are not that
mysterious now and working Tec into them
and curative ways is not that mysterious
the biggest challenge is structural and
institutional where in like if when one
One Laptop Per child went into Ethiopia
where we have a big office so it's been
a lot of time there I mean their laptops
were perceived by the teachers there as
a pain in the ass because kids just were
playing with these cool educational
games and you know making simulations
composing music but that was distracting
attention from passing the exam that
would get them into university quite
challenging in Ethiopia so what you need
is to make the system embrace
progressive education which is actually
harder than harder than defining how the
progressive education should work
because there's even the tool they're
able to pursue what they love but then
the systems requirements are you must
fit into these boxes yeah yeah yeah and
they're like not a high percentage can
go to college so if you fail that
university entrance exam it's bad it's
not like the u.s. whoever we can go to
university yeah and China is the same
way like the university entrance exam is
a huge deal really so you need if that
exam is the focus and there's a limited
amount of creativity that parents can
let their kids pursue right
so this one unfortunately so like
reforming the world's AI tech ecosystem
I sort of see how to do like from the
side but I just build this decentralized
network you know outsource services to
businesses from this networking let the
whole thing spread on the other hand
performing the world's education system
I don't see a way to do other than like
work with governments to to reform what
how they do assessment and an evaluation
should because I mean otherwise you can
provide all the cool like downloadable
curriculum you want but if it's not what
kids are forced to do when sitting in
school eight hours a day and then it's
gonna have a real but limited impact by
putting the assessments and examinations
on the children we're automatically
siloing time from them those areas which
then takes away from the other creative
endeavors that they might be minute
about so UNESCO is interesting and
they're embracing both advanced tech and
progressive education so I'm trying to
I'm working with them to to work with
with ministries of Education in
different in different countries then
what are you not doing sleeping sleeping
exactly that's what you're not doing you
are an amazing human being this has been
such a pleasure to talk and unpack this
even in his first preliminary stages
whatever we can do to help with our
network of an builders will do as well
as hopefully when you're back in the Bay
we can do live events you know promoting
Dai and an even more that you're going
to do so you know we can do that with
Lisa
we love Lisa as well so thank you again
so much for coming all right yeah thanks
thanks for all the good questions sure
yeah there's too many questions to ask
yeah he's so awesome
thanks everyone for tuning in give us a
comment below with your thoughts about
what we talked about it's so much to
unpack also join the telegram during the
public telegram join us there and also
go build the future go build your
destiny into the world going
a fest that thanks everyone for tuning
in much love we'll see you soon
[Music]